your style is not that easily packed
into a short set
because you tend to be more storyteller
long form you
take your time and these are all
compliments you're not just calling me
lazy
yeah take your time tell these stories
he's always got an excuse
you're more of a marathoner and i'm
going hey i've got this 50 yard dash i
want you to run
yeah well also like you're the first
person to ever call me
a racer of any kind so
a lot of work goes into a short late
night stand-up set join me
jp buck as i spotlight the comedians who
came up with some of my favorite coin
sets
this is the setup please welcome back to
our show very funny guys shane torres
let's talk about this guy fieri said how
does this thought come to you
i always wanted to tell jokes that
nobody else could tell
right like meaning they were mine uh
like and there was a that's him it
sounds like him right away
one of the things i would always see
people doing as far as subject matter
goes
was just be like the the easiest way to
like say something is shitty is like
it's like guy fieri blah blah blah
it was like something i saw people doing
forever and i really
i thought it was um kind of a dumb way
to pack a parachute
it just was like unimaginative to me and
like not really well researched and just
very much in my mind a bit lazy when i
was seeing about you know like
because i know it and it's not not even
to say it doesn't work
but it wasn't something i found like
terribly exciting
it was like top 40 radio to me so i kind
of thought
well what's different like like what
what is he actually you know like oh
like why did why just think about it for
a second because
it's also the opinion everybody hold
held about him
at the time was like just unanimous that
he sucked
you know like and i was like well maybe
he doesn't well
let's find out you know it started with
the very opening line of the joke that's
the one thing
that didn't really change ever that much
was like can someone please explain to
me
what the hell guy fieri ever did to
anyone
the first time i did it i did it at
whiplash
uh on the west side in manhattan and it
got a huge
pop and i was like i remember it being i
was like oh this is a good joke because
i had to follow judd apatow
so i was like so i was like well if i'm
keeping up with the king of hollywood
i'm doing
all right it would be hard to do a bit
like this say back in like the 80s
before social media before this sort of
uniformity of thought of where people
were just sort of like the hive mind of
like oh that guy hates it yeah i'm on
board with that yeah
it just kind of became that like
negativity was just an opinion on him
but it wasn't informed
and it's kind of a way people are in
general
which is like it's just like that that
person sucks this sucks that sucks and
there was never like
okay sure you can like i understand how
to react to something when you don't
like it
but i also think you should still
explain it but also like how often
like does do you need to hate like you
know someone like guy fieri
like really is he ever like in your is
he in your house is it your place at
work
are you interacting with him like what's
the why carry around that
yeah well and then there's like a there
was a guy i met and i thought this was
actually very interesting it's like you
don't even know you do it but he goes
like he
guy in austin i think he's in brendan k
o'grady and he just goes and goes
hey that bit's great and just so you
know i make fun of him
but the very first thing i do whenever
i'm on the road is see if guy fieri's
been to a restaurant there
what i love also is you come right out
the box
delivering a lot you know you have that
first line you're not worried about an
opener you're not trying to do it like
how's everybody
i don't know if you remember we talked
about you're like you're calling me like
hey i love the bit and i think it's
going to be great
but it is all one bit so like
just so you know if they don't like it
you can't
you it's not you know it's not the
seller at 130 you can't pivot out of it
you gotta you can't be like where would
they go with that guy fieri thing and
then two minutes later it's all
everything bagels or whatever
yeah so i did think like maybe i should
just give them one
like very soft thing like just to get
them like hey
real quick but then it was kind of like
ah [ __ ] it it's a little more fun to
just be excited and
and see how it goes
can someone please explain to me
what the hell guy fieri ever
did to anyone y'all know who i'm talking
about the celebrity chef
people [ __ ] on that dude all the time
and as far as i can tell all he ever did
was follow his dreams
do you understand people are horrible
to a television personality and he
didn't do
anything wrong here's what he did do
america the audience is sometimes the
late-night sets
in studios or can be a little tight and
that
joe that line i've seen every time gets
a huge pop
and deservedly so every once in a while
we get audiences they
are not as great as other audiences that
happens everywhere
yeah they're kind of leaning in going
okay where are you going with this you
know like when you're doing these big
sets i'm sure
everyone's told you this but like you
you're like
oh my first little thing didn't get the
thing
didn't get like what i expect of it and
you're like oh [ __ ] this is
god i feel like i've been up here an
hour already look at that
you're like 20 seconds in what one joke
like i'm such a [ __ ] tin man armor
kind of guy
like i really i was cause i remember
thinking it would just get like this
loud pop and then i was just gonna rev
in and hit him for
four and a half minutes or whatever it
is you know and then i remember it
feeling
like good like it worked but it wasn't
like what i was expecting
and and then i remember like i kind of
felt like i was moving a little faster
you've got them already but like it's
like it like you can definitely tell
you've got a little bit of a task ahead
of you of going okay yeah this group of
people
needs a little softening up he started a
company where he hires everybody
he pays more than minimum wage he gives
health benefits before he has to
he has a non-profit where he gives
pretzel making machines to schools so
they can fundraise
i know that one sounds like i made it up
but i swear to christ it's true
you also have phrases everyone's all
like that that are purely yours the
swear to christ
it's another one of those like i don't
write jokes well so i have to figure out
a way to say things that are funny
i would not agree with that i mean i
don't write them like
like punchline-y like someone who is
great but i'm not like him at all it's
like sam morrell you know like his acts
are
his is it is very punchy and very dense
i think i have to just be like here i am
this dumb
country rube with all his weird sayings
or whatever
i like writing that way it feels like
more creative it's a fun way to be
creative and
not take an easy way out and just see
like
it's the craziest thing ever you know
like that's like kind of lazy
writing so like it's funner to
embody like a good like turn of phrase
if you will he works with special
olympics
athletes and if you need a little more
sugar with this medicine
he also officiated a gay wedding
yeah but because he has flames on his
shirt everybody shits all over this dude
like he's a member of nickelback
and by the way what the hell did
nickelback ever do
they made 40 million bros happy yeah you
don't want them walking around pissed
off that's how we ended up in this mess
the nickelback thing did that start out
as just a line and something like oh
wait i can actually mine this
a little more for a joke it started out
as an is-like joke like which is not a
thing i'm
like i said i'm not a huge fan of but i
think you can take them further
like it's just the first step up the
stairs like but
i said it and i was like that's good
it'll work it's another thing people
dog for no reason i didn't research
they're not researched in the bit the
way like
guys here so they may actually be
horrible people
yeah they might be but i saw somebody
write a thing about that guy from
nickelback
like he's a genius because he knows
exactly what people want and that's what
he gets them and i was like
hey man that's a [ __ ] very good point
i think i read it on consequence of
sound or something like that
but i was like i wish i could credit
whoever wrote it but i was like yeah
that's true
it's just it's right there that's what
they want they want to rock
just enough and
he gives it to him every time nobody
gives anybody a a 7 out of 10 like chad
and kroger i get it i don't want to hang
out with guy fieri either okay
i know he looks like a hot topic manager
moonlighting at a fridays
but he didn't do anything wrong
well what else has he done shane i'm
so glad you asked he goes around the
country to small businesses and gives
them free advertising on a national
platform on a weekly basis
advertising those small businesses could
never afford themselves with his own
television show
but because his hair looks like he was
electrocuted while drinking mountain dew
people act like we need to saw his hat
off and put it on the internet
it does feel like you're involved in the
audience and like even there in that set
you do say you know you do play the
audience and what else does he do shane
yeah you you ask the question on their
behalf even if they're not asking you
keep it going yeah
real special kind of [ __ ] it takes to
do something like that
it's a way to check in with them without
like halting all the information and
like making it directly conversational
like as opposed to being
like are you enjoying this like or you
know like because there's also no room
for that in a late night set
there's not like i mean like you can't
just do crowd work meanwhile
y'all can't get enough of anthony
bourdain
now we'll stop it here for a second okay
yeah because i feel like we do need to
need to address this there's a part in
this bit where
i do a kind of side-by-side comparative
of the two
uh food personalities and anthony
bourdain was like such a darling
yeah and uh i take the
what do you want to say like an inverted
position
on it like of like why he might suck
and kind of use the lot the surface
logic of
that people would use against guy fear
that he just sucks because his hair is
like this or
he acts like this and i do the same
thing to
anthony bourdain uh in the bit
pre his death is that emma saying this
right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think it's you're not i didn't write
this like
into a eulogy or anything you know like
i'm not a [ __ ] animal
yeah you're not aiming anything
personally at anthony bourdain this is
just purely
the sensationalization of anthony
bourdain by the media and the fans
uh yeah and i will say before we go into
this part
uh i uh i was
performing at bonnaroo when bourdain
died and
i was on i was having a good time and
uh marianne who booked comedy there was
just like i need somebody on stage right
now
and i just kind of went into autopilot
and i hadn't done this bit
and maybe since this show and i just i
did the
i did this bit and he had died the day
before
and i like get to the bourdain part and
everybody was just like whoa
ah i wrote this before yesterday i'm
gonna just kind of plowed ahead
and it went over fine but it was one of
those moments where i was like
[ __ ] they just get canceled while the
killers were playing in the background
or whatever
but and he seems like the kind of dude
that would be mean to dogs
so i don't understand what is happening
what does he do so i put on rolling
stones t-shirts and i tell food courts
they suck come on man
like if you had to choose between being
stuck in a foxhole with anthony bourdain
or guy fieri you're going to pick fieri
every time
i am still doing this bit i love that
line
like it goes on for
it's kind of a lot the the bit you know
when did you feel you needed to include
like letting people know like yes we're
i'm aware that this is going on but
we're going to keep going i remember
like it was like growing in the bit was
like coming into fruition and it kind of
like
i was really into doing the bit for a
little bit like a lot of comments are
and i would do it at like a cool show or
whatever and the people when the crowds
i wanted to be killing in front of would
be like
jesus it's killing i would like i would
note and they were like i was such a
surprise you know
because i hadn't really i'd done some tv
stuff but i wasn't like a famous person
yet you know like in la or new york and
i'm not
famous now but what i'm saying like i
got to show that i could have the best
game of the night or whatever out of all
the people on the show
and that bit was something that was
doing it if that makes sense
and i would see like it build and build
and build and then i would like and it
would be going well
and that would be like and that kind of
like was like well what would be like
the funniest thing i could possibly do
or what is a funny thing i could do in
this bit and i was just like
i could just acknowledge that this is
taking a while even if it's going well
so to me it's just funny to harp on
something for
way longer than people want to hear it
what's more dane gonna do
i'll tell you to be like that dude in
every world war ii movie who sucks the
whole time
then when the nazis show up doesn't do
his job
gets a bunch of good soldiers killed
meanwhile guy fieri's over here earning
new nicknames like el
fuego picking up live grenades throwing
them back
saying dope [ __ ] like welcome to flavor
town
and he knows he's dying on that beach in
france that morning but he's there
fighting
and what do you all do you [ __ ] all over
him just because he had his sunglasses
on the back of his neck
i think it's awesome that he has a
racing stripe painted on his fridge
love it if banksy had painted it
and look guys i know i look like the
kind of dude that would defend guy fieri
but if that's what you're taking away
from this you're missing the point
thank you guys very much i'm shane
torres really appreciate it
jake gordy says first time i saw this i
was 100
on board with the fiery hate train by
the end this dude had completely
persuaded me on how and why i was wrong
that's the one i liked them i've gotten
like some variations of that and that is
like
that is the nicest thing i think i think
it's cool
like you know i really think it's like
it's cool that like
it's a dumb joke about something that is
not important
you know like in the grand but it's it's
nice to
it's really nice to see people can
change their minds who are just
solidified
in a thought and then yeah that's what's
cool about that brian c
says he positions himself at a strange
angle i know where
you know where i'm going with this yeah
for a lot of this segment so strange
that it was only that the 10-second mark
that i knew he had two hands
[Laughter]
that's i've not heard that uh
i don't yeah i i know people it's just
whatever i do it for whatever reason and
it just kind of ended up being this
weird thing i do
uh when i perform i've had a few people
call it teapotting
which it's like this is kind of the
thing i like about it because i'm shaped
like one too
but uh i like uh i don't
people bring it up and they're uh
it's just whatever i don't know man i
just do it
[Music]
you know i know the bit did well and
everything and like did well on the show
and then on youtube and all like
it did well on the internet but anytime
he
does something now at all in the news i
get tagged in it
and then like it's somebody said like
hey i own a restaurant he came to it
anytime we re-air
like our episode we airs where we have i
know i have to have extra waiters on
that weekend
yeah like so i just i think that's very
cool yeah it's really cool but then
there's the
the other part which is the curse of
fiery that you're getting notified about
this all the time
it's it's a i mean it's a small cross to
bear for a man who's done so much for
america